listen you got to get your bombs
delivered somehow and i trust the u.s
postal service too then
uh we have a guest we have a guest
why are you here adam
i wish i knew
is going to explain
uh romania this is [ __ ] stupid so
[ __ ] stupid
pour down all those buildings for no
reason it's like jazz it's about the
buildings you don't build
so we have to talk about something
called the warsaw pact and the good guys
yes
if you're on the spectrum of communism
oh we're all on the spectrum
there is actually a very very bad man in
communism
uh and that guy was nikolai chaucesco
the person responsible for his interior
design was elena jesco was inspired i
guess by by her foreign trips so this
this is basically like the pinterest
influence before pinterest yes
and small moist chunks of asbestos
dropping down on you when you're
swimming
north korea or you like to call it korea
korea yes exactly
clearly this is the way we make romania
a world power i mean there was a whole
central place for a meaty can opening i
really appreciated that chesco
when he sat down in front of him
had
most enormous
balls
that explains everything invisible
through the pants
what happened
to nikolai and elena ceausescu g shucks
am i excited to tell you
[Music]
uh alice could i get the drop please
hi my name is nikolae chojesko and you
might be wondering how i ended up in
this situation
[Music]
you